things seem to be in steep decline over
at national public radio npr's own media
reporter destroyed a lengthy piece
explaining that the white supremacy
they're so concerned about is coming
from inside the house
npr struggles to retain high-profile
journalists of color hosts have
complained to the network's leadership
of pay disparities along racial and
gender lines well that sounds systemic
and weird considering 99 of npr's
programming
is about promoting equity so what's
going on here well to investigate we
listen to many more hours of npr here's
part of what we heard
so diet culture is this overarching
system of beliefs and values it's really
endemic to western culture at this point
in history
christie harrison is an anti-diet
registered dietitian with a master's in
public health
so there was an anti-diet dietitian
then when we kept listing we're
introduced to a fitness expert who hates
fitness listen
i was and still am in a lot of ways
triggered by hearing the word fitness
because even before you kind of get
engrossed in fitness culture
you are inundated into diet culture and
some of the toxic messages there is a
growing movement to make fitness culture
a more inclusive one
ilya parker is a leading voice in that
effort in fact that was ilia's voice you
heard talking about how fitness is a
trigger word
ilya is a physical therapist assistant a
certified medical exercise specialist
and the owner of decolonizing fitness
so here we have a fat fitness
constructor and that's okay
trying to figure out why is npr
collapsing exactly i mean it's kind of
baffling so we kept listening then we
learned according to npr that if you're
going to decolonize fitness that means
you can't let the doctor weigh you
because scales are relics of colonialism
and white supremacy
if you're going to your doctor one thing
is that you do not have to be weighed it
is your right to decline to be weighed
and so that you certainly can decline
when you go the other thing is to let
your provider know that you would like
medical care from a health at every size
perspective and that you would not
want to discuss weight or weight
management at your visit that you have
the right to ask for that
we should tell you that all these clips
are from just one episode that aired
last week so now we know why all these
people are leaving npr it's not racism
they're just embarrassed but not us
we're no longer going to criticize npr
we're fans we're going to keep listing
nothing like this has ever appeared on
the airwaves anywhere it's hilarious
treat yourself hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else